sitting in court as he's handed a
12-year jail sentence the scene is a far
cry from his former life of luxury
the son of mozambique's former president
was among 11 people found guilty in a
corruption case known as the tuna Bond
scandal
it involves state-owned companies
illicitly borrowing hundreds of millions
of dollars from International Banks to
fund a tuna fishing operation and
surveillance vessels
but the cash disappeared and
mozambique's government hid the
borrowing from both Parliament and the
public
when the full scale of the Hidden debt
came to light in 2016 it triggered an
economic crisis in Mozambique
the country's currency lost a third of
its value inflation surged and foreign
donors pulled out
former president Amando gabuza who was
in office when The loans were agreed
testified at the trial his son was found
guilty of influencing his father to get
the government to approve the deals
and of using a 33 million dollar bribe
to buy luxury cars and a mansion in
South Africa eight of the 19 defendants
were acquitted while the rest were given
prison terms ranging between 10 and 12
years
handing down the sentences the judge
said the scam had plunged thousands of
people into poverty across the country
many outside the court said the Judgment
sent a clear message
to those who are still willing to commit
such crimes that there's no it is no
longer
and the country
where you can come in such crime and and
walk free
so I think that those who orchestrated
this
crime will not go free
as
we used to see in this country back in
the days
the debt Scandal exposed corruption on a
global scale and sparked legal cases
across three continents given Calvert Al
Jazeera